hey this is presh talwalker
ABCD is a square
to the bottom right of ABCD construct an
identical Square c e f g
to the right of this Square construct
another identical square e h i f
construct a i which intersects BC at
Point J and intersect CE at Point k
suppose the area of triangle cjk is
exactly equal to one square meter
the question is what is the area of one
of these three identical squares
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
there are many ways to work this out
here is one method
construct another identical square d c g
l
now triangle cjk is similar to Triangle
l a i
furthermore triangle cjk and Lai are
similar to Triangle Dak
so suppose a side length of the square a
d is equal to s
so every single square has a side length
equal to s
in similar triangles ratios of
corresponding sides are equal to each
other
so let's work this out
l i divided by L A is equal to DK
divided by d a
this means that 3s divided by 2s is
equal to DK divided by S
we can solve this equation for DK to get
the DK is equal to 3s divided by 2.
but now we know that DC is equal to S
because it's a side length of the square
so we take the length of DK and subtract
the length of DC we get the length of c
k and that means c k is equal to S over
2.
next CJ divided by c k is equal to d a
divided by DK and this is equal to 2
divided by 3.
but we know that CK is equal to S over 2
. so we can solve this equation for CJ
to get that C J is equal to S over 3.
so now let's just focus on triangle cjk
we know that its area is equal to one
but it's also equal to one-half
multiplied by S over three multiplied by
S over 2. this simplifies to be S
squared divided by 12 is equal to 1
which means s squared is equal to 12.
but the area of the square is exactly
equal to S squared so the area of the
square is equal to 12 square meters and
that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign
[Music]